de chinon à montargis et de dreux toute
la région centre est différent tout de
même le nord de la région ayant été plus
durement touchés que le sud impossible à
l'heure actuelle d'évaluer précisément
les dégâts
quelques chiffres significatifs
toutefois dans le seul département du
loiret les pompiers sont intervenus près
de six mille fois depuis hier et pour
plus de 1300 dégâts sérieux de toiture
un chiffre qui ne prend pas en compte
tous les autres dégâts mineurs quelques
tuiles envolées une simple vente hier
par un chien
la circulation automobile la gare poser
de problème aujourd'hui sauf pour
quelques routes secondaires
actuel est très localisée trafic
ferroviaire est fortement perturbé en
bière a repris progressivement
aujourd'hui quelques difficultés ont
persisté cependant sur l'année pour le
mans en ce qui concerne l'alimentation
en électricité le plus gros problème
encore actuellement près de 80 mille
foyers sont encore privés de courant sur
l'ensemble de la région
alors que les flocons de neige ont fait
leur apparition dans tunis dans le chien
est la situation en revanche de vos
difficultés persistent dans trois
départements 35 mille foyers sont
toujours privés de courant dans l'est et
le sud du loiret dix mille personnes
dans le loir-et-cher en eure-et-loir 25
mille clients de l'edf attendent le
retour du courant dont les résidents de
la maison de retraite de la perte
évitables
enfin le manque d'électricité provoque
également des problèmes d'alimentation
de certains châteaux problème réglé
provisoirement grâce à l'installation de
groupes électrogènes